foreign
Julie Is With Us in Springfield Missouri
hi Julie how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up
um so we've pulled our house back in
August and we are still sitting on the
money that we got back from it
um so my question is should we throw all
that money towards the debt
um and could we use part of it as a down
payment for a house or should we put it
all on today how much money do you have
seventeen thousand and how much debt do
you have
23 7. what's your household income
um it actually just increased it went
from 50 and we're around 90 now good for
you
and where are you living now
we are actually in a camper we bought a
used fifth wheel whenever we sold our
house so we're going a little crazy we
have two kids and two dogs and a 45
camper so how old are yeah
I'm 28 my husband's 32. why'd you sell
your house
[Applause]
reason um
okay
um 17K from the home sale
um
23.7 a day are you work currently
working this snowball have you started
paying off other debts yet
we haven't no okay do you have a
thousand dollars saved
we do okay that's only three thousand
that's true so we'll start with a
thousand dollars saved I I guess what
I'm looking for I want to make sure that
you're committed to a process going
forward
because it's going to take you being
committed to this process or else you're
gonna go she told me to take this money
and pay off my debt and then and you're
gonna feel like you were up a creek so
you've gotta rent a house
and pay off your debt
okay
and pay off your debt by Chris pay off
your debt by Christmas
okay and then then build an emergency
fund and then build a down payment and
buy another house
okay and with
um with our pay range what what would
you suggest
um like uh for the amount of house we
should get you know so we've got a
calculator that's located on our site
but the parameters there is we never
want the payment your monthly payment to
be any more than 25 of your take-home
pay and that's everything all in that's
taxes Insurance HOA fees everything and
then when you go to buy the house you
want it to be on a 15-year fixed rate
conventional mortgage that's what you're
looking for
okay thank you guys so much so here's
the thing here's what it's going to feel
like truly number one
you're going to get your sanity back
this week go find a rental house
okay something something reasonable
because you're going to be there for a
year maybe a year and a half
so get something to read and then sell
the camper sell the camper what will the
camper bring
uh we bought it used for 20. I'm
assuming we could only get about like 17
out of it okay so now if you take that
17 in your other 17 you're debt free
yes then you're going to build up three
to six months of expenses so you're
going to be sitting on another 15 000
cash
is your next goal
okay okay but you're gonna be there
pretty quick you may be there by
Christmas
now that I'm now that I got the camper
sold I forgot about how much it was
going to bring okay so we're dealing
with 34 you're dealing with nine
thousand dollars in your savings account
after you sell the camper and pay off
17.
okay no I'm sorry you're dealing with um
you have you're on one you're gonna
you're gonna have your emergency fund
pretty close yeah no no no no no no no
34 no you're on 9000 in there so yeah
you got to go and you got to put another
six thousand in by Christmas and here's
the thing you gotta breathe this in for
a second you're living in a nice rental
home not super pot not super expensive
because we don't want to spend too much
okay but but a whole lot better in your
situation today
okay there's a little bit of physical
room for your family to relax
I want you to hear I want you to get
this picture
the kids are calm there's a little
physical privacy and space there's
fifteen thousand dollars cash in the
bank
you don't have a payment in the world
that feels pretty darn good
yes yes for sure now we shave up a big
down payment we buy a house in the next
two years and you're doing that from a
position of strength not desperation and
frantic I gotta get out
work
where I am right now I would be too
so does that make sense for that yes no
it's called Financial Peace
if you work this system that's what you
get that's right got to be committed to
it that's how it works there's a process
here so Jade is exactly right you've got
to lay a process in there step-by-step
game plan to attack this renting is not
a sin folks
it's patience while you get your crap
together that's right and that's what we
laid out here my husband and I we rented
for 10 years well we paid off our debt
well you paid off 465 000 in debt that's
right but we understood what was on the
the end of it which is why I say when
you go into these things understand it's
a plan it's something for the Long Haul
and you've got to understand that going
in otherwise Midway through you'll bail
on it